frenchy merci alors atteint déjà
commencé bout 18 minutes claque donc
rapidement l'homme interface et les
frontières bon je pense que vous avez
tous vu le lancement de la coupe du
monde je veux commencer par ça parce que
la coupe du monde et puis goldorak me
suis dit c'est peut-être ma génération
j'ai pas trop
alors pour aller dans le dossier s'il
vous plaît je veux montrer tout de suite
deux vidéos un de vidéos parce que je
suis vous avez regardé la coupe du monde
le début nous avait pas vu quelque chose
qui s'est passé et il est où le dossier
donc deux vidéos la première c'est le
lancement vraiment de la coupe du monde
c'est à dire là où était donné le coup
d'envoi
alors là ça sera plutôt côté goldorak et
vous allez voir c'est très intéressant
la pâte à dent initiale dans le mondial
allait voir sa toque regarder ça dure 30
secondes
voyez donc qu'est ce que c'est ça c'est
exactement une personne donc et
tétraplégique et qui équipé d'un
exosquelette référence à goldorak et qui
par sa pensée shoot dans un ballon c'est
à dire que l'information ait récupéré au
niveau du cerveau 1 c'est pas et après
tu as qu il ya donc l'exosquelette qui
agit donc ça c'est le lancement de la
coupe du monde premier seconde exemple
2011 ça a un peu changé ma carrière de
chercheur donc à ce moment-là qu'est ce
que l'on voit une personne tétraplégique
là aussi un casque ou électrodes fait
exactement et pilotes par la pensée un
robot voyez c'est à dire la caisse qui
se passent l'information est directement
récupérés nettoyées de tout ce qui ne
convient pas et le robot récupère cette
information est fait que à un moment
donné va lui porter ce ver là donc voilà
très rapidement pour rentrer dans notre
conférence comme ça vous saisissez mieux
l'homme interface et où les frontières
de l'humain donc s'estompe avec la
technique
voyez donc c'est ça à un moment donné
j'ai souhaité dire
et donc deux notions les notions
importantes qui apparaissent aujourd'hui
et notamment celui qui interroge sa
singularité
c'est à dire on se pose la question
qu'est ce qu'un humain en fait
aujourd'hui quand on commence à bricoler
à ce niveau là et ça c'est extrêmement
intéressant dans notre champ dans le
champ des sciences de l'information et
de la communication c'est à dire on voit
bien quelque chose de nouveau
il ya quelque chose ou ce champ là à à
se saisir c'est à dire le traitement de
l'information mais aussi la
communication humaine qu'est ce qu'il a
qu'est ce qu'il reste d'humain et donc
l'apparition de cet homme
interfacé fait que les relations
établies entre le vivant et l'artificiel
se modifie donc deuxième information
on a deux choses à retenir un déjà la
question des frontières
on voit bien par rapport à la technique
deuxième main la question et on va y
revenir là dessus de la convergence
entre le vivant et l'artificiel
notamment à travers la notion de données
et là je vais donner un sigle ntic il ya
dix ans 2002 un rapport ntic où on voit
très bien
cette convergence qui apparaît nbc nano
bio informatique sciences cognitives qui
font que cette convergence entre le
vivant artificielle fait que là
aujourd'hui on intervient de façon très
précise pour des choses que certains
annoncent d'une certaine manière donc
entre le vivant et l'artificiel
voilà ce que je vous ai montré en fait
il ya cathy johnson c'est ce que vous
avez vu tétraplégique un bras robotisé
donc je cite le chercheur jolyane pitot
2014 1 c'est là c'est maintenant un
jeune paraplégique a shooté dans le
premier ballon vous voyez et 2045
donc ce qu'a annoncé par sans faire leur
publicité ce que je partage pas ce qui
est dit mary kurt weill et le mouvement
des transhumanistes annonce une nouvelle
ère pour l'humain donc le mouvement des
transhumanistes si vous tapez
transhumanistes est crucial vous allez
tomber sur des sites sur une très grande
discussion mais il faut bien voir que
c'est google directement qui à travers
ça donc qu'est-ce qui projette en grosse
base sur la loi de moore une
multiplication des capacités de
l'informatique disque en 2045
eh bien on va basculer à une nouvelle
ère par rapport à sa bande
on pourrait bien évidemment discuter
tout ça au regard de ce qui s'est dit
mais c'est extrêmement intéressant de
voir les investissements qui sont faits
à ce niveau là par rapport à ça et donc
aussi comment l'humain et on le voit
bien tous les jours comment l'humain on
le perçoit différemment on le perçoit
relier on le perçoit hybride et on le
perçoit
d'une certaine manière augmenté et moi
je suis beaucoup plus du côté de l'homme
diminué parce qu'on sait très bien que
c'est parce qu'on est diminué que on va
aussi avancé mais c'est intéressant de
le voir alors ted
d'abord je remercie les organisateurs de
de ted de m'avoir invité et c'est vrai
que j'ai lu un article là dans le monde
je pense que tous les étudiants lisent
le monde alors c'est pas nécessaire de
deux d'en faire trop la référence le
monde voyez marque et aide le show de la
pensée est alors je me suis dit en
lisant ça je me suis dit qu'ils se
soient un peu trompé quoi parce que
voilà il faudrait un peu nuancer leur
propos vous voyez ils disent que t'es de
ne participe à l'esprit critique au
débat ne participe à un petit peu ces
questions humaines et bien vivant en
étant là en ayant écouté christian en
étant là présent donc vraiment un grand
merci aux organisateurs
parce que il me semble ici sur notre
territoire à toulon donc je vais revenir
l'année prochaine est un pari depuis
deux ans sur notre territoire
on a quelque chose à saisir par rapport
à ça c'est à dire le travail qui est
fait depuis des années on le connaît
bien au niveau de l'université avec
toulon var technologies c'est à dire
qu'entre les entreprises les
collectivités territoriales et les
chercheurs il ya une dynamique où on
voit bien ici qu'à s'inscrit
complètement mais aussi quelque chose
que l'on doit faire apparaître et
insister là dessus c'est à dire des
lieux où se produisent des décalages
c'est à dire des lieux où un moment
donné on n'est pas dans une continuité
des choses on n'est pas dans une
répétition mais des lieux où il ya une
certaine émergence du nouveau wind
certaines créations ou monde peut être
surpris et il me semble que ce lieu en
est emblématique
mais il a où il ya des décalages c'est
aussi par des rencontres c'est pas
forcément parce qu'on va diluer à
travers la matière numérique des tas de
choses parce que va rencontrer la
différence et donc on va rencontrer
l'altérité donc un grand merci aux
organisateurs de ted
donc pour en revenir à l'homme interface
et quel type de questions peut-on poser
aujourd'hui quand on lit le monde et
vous voyez j'ai fait des références sur
des choses extrêmement récente c'est à
dire qu'ils sont publiés
au mois de juin et bien voilà on annonce
des voitures qui vont qui vend qui vont
conduire sans son conducteur
on annonce aussi au niveau de la
génétique je veux dire et notre
génération à la bricoler dans le jeu et
dans le garage est le fait du
rock'n'roll mais aussi à la bricoler des
systèmes informatiques mais aujourd'hui
ce qu'on bricole dans les garages ce à
travers des kits génétique c'est ça on
fait du copier coller en coupe
en face à une certaine chose donc autre
information pour ceux qui s'intéressent
et qui viennent des technologies quand
on lit le robot eugène goodman a réagi a
réussi le test de turing c'est là c'est
le monde 11 juin voyez c'est en plein
milieu de la coupe du monde quoi je veux
dire ce sont des choses dont on doit se
saisir maintenant je veux dire est que
nous chercheurs on doit pas être là
simplement je veux dire avec un un côté
tout va bien tout ça ne veut pas dire
que tout va mal mais on doit se saisir
ça on doit le questionner on doit se
dire qu'est ce qu'il se passe on doit
pas créer forcément une énième
commission d'éthique parce qu'il y en a
des commissions d'éthique dont douar
alimenté en termes de contenu cela et on
doit rencontrer ceux qui participent les
industriels nous chercheurs le monde
les acteurs de la société on doit les
rencontrer par rapport à ça on doit
discuter ensemble on doit provoquer des
décalages et etc etc
et c'est là à ce moment là que via
l'innovation parce que l'imprévu elle
est faite à partir de rencontres
donc je vais vous parler d'un ouvrage
qui s'appelle l'autre n'est pas une
donnée altérité correct et fat et de la
revue mais c'est là où je travaille ce
numéro a été coordonné par benoit
leblanc samuel lepastier moi même on
vient de sortir l'autre n'est pas une
donnée c'est à dire l'autre pour ça que
je parle de rencontre n'est pas une
donnée n'est pas qu'une donnée
actuellement envoyés et alors ce qui est
extrêmement intéressant dans cet ouvrage
on vient de le sortir d'abord la revue
hermès est la revue dirigée par
dominique wolton dominique wolton était
ici dans ses murs il ya quelques
semaines est vraiment ça a été un
travail incroyable on a fait travailler
philosophe personnes des sciences
cognitives psychanalyste des personnes
en info com est vraiment tout le monde
s'est réuni autour de cette question de
l'humain mais de la communication
humaine voiliers et sont intervenus à
des collègues
je leur ai demandé mais là on parle de
ntic mais d'où ça vient
on parle des logiciels de
recommandations et d'où ça vient un
moment donné donc voyez qu'est ce qui se
passe et qui est intéressant à travers
ça
ouvrage c'est qu'en fait il ya trois
choses que je vais nommer il ya disons
les frontières avec l'humain qui sont à
interroger ses frontières vraiment c on
voit bien qu'à s'estompe actuellement à
un moment donné il ya aussi cette
convergence à travers leur difficiel le
vivant je reviens là dessus mais aussi à
travers donc le fait que par la
rencontre et par l'inattendu on peut
prouver que hors autre chose je vais
insister sur quelque chose sur cette
notion de continuité discontinuité on
voit bien que quand on se branche
regardez ce qui se passe quand on
branche quelqu'un sur son cerveau nos
enfants dans quelques temps vont avoir
ils ont déjà des jeux vidéos qui vont
piloter mais ça va transmettre de
l'information aux producteurs je veux
dire qu'ils ont eux mêmes par des
logiciels qu'on va vont traiter ces
données
actuellement il y a tout un travail qui
se fait au niveau des données publiques
on le sait très bien au niveau des deux
n'est aussi personnelle et ce maillage
l'a fait que l'on à travers des
logiciels qu'on appelait des logiciels
de recommandation on a tendance à
vouloir prédire d'une certaine d'une
certaine manière la venir évidemment la
question du corps je veux dire c'est une
des parties importantes de cet ouvrage
la question du corps c'est à dire est ce
que le corps humain devient objet est ce
que le corps devient informations est ce
que devient ce corps là ce corps qui va
que l'on va un moment donné et bien
pouvoir le transforment et quoi c'est à
dire et en faire une économie la
bioéconomie jorand vos textes de céline
lafontaine est extrêmement important et
à travers ça à travers la notion de
données et du traitement de
l'information
on voit aussi qu'il ya une notion
importante quelle émotion domeo stasi
c'est-à-dire de régulation c'est à dire
comment on régule ensemble à partir des
données c'est-à-dire au moment où les
cadres symbolique un souk les textes
tous qui pendant le xxème siècle a eu
tendance à s'estomper font que
maintenant il ya des dispositifs qui
sont mis en place à partir de cette
matière là à partir de cette matière
numérique
donc il est vrai que cette revue je veux
dire est vraiment un endroit
extraordinaire où des personnes de
différentes disciplines se rend compte
moi j'ai beaucoup appris j'ai beaucoup
appris au contact de pouce peut citer
quelques collègues de bernard valade par
exemple mais aussi de jacques périllaud
jacques perriot est un homme
extraordinaire qui parle quand il parle
de l'empreinte de la technique on voit
très bien
ce qui peut s'y passer quand on parle de
cet homme là de cet homme augmenté
il ya un ouvrage inquiets qui est celui
de jean michel besnier vous voyez donc
autant de scientifiques et moment donné
se pose de ces questions là nous ici à
toulon je veux dire articulé avec ce qui
peut se faire ailleurs notamment à paris
dont on peut profiter de cette dynamique
là faire que des lieux comme vous vous
avez créé ici à travers tête mais
d'autres aussi au sein de l'université
donc un véritable projet universitaire
qui s'articule au monde de l'entreprise
et au monde et des collectivités
territoriales face que en plus de la
réflexion on produise des décalages et
de l'innovation mais par la rencontre
voilà un petit peu ce que je souhaite
vous transmettre aujourd'hui est donc
cet homme interface et je veux dire j'ai
tellement accéléré que c'est ma dernière
diapos alors tranquille je vais pouvoir
enfin de parler cet homme interface et
je veux dire donc comme je les cités
c'est à dire que les biens il ya des il
ya des auteurs qui se penche sur cette
question là et cette question fait qu'à
un moment donné et bien on se pose tout
simplement la question de ce qu'est
l'humain alors je vais entrer un peu
plus en détail sur cette question là
aujourd'hui parce que il est vrai que
quand on pose cette question c'est une
question de tellement complexe quoi mais
moi j'ai quand même repérer certaines
choses que je vais jouer un petit peu
développée avec vous j'ai repéré
notamment à la lecture des ouvrages très
récente
un jouet licite et qu'un qui s'appelle
l'humain qui a été écrit par par monique
atlan et roger pol droit
un autre bon j'ai cité jean michel
besnier mais il ya aussi par exemple un
philosophe qui dirige le départ acquis à
diriger le département des comptes
nationale supérieure de lui et n'est ce
donc un qui s'appelle francis francis
wolff il ya aussi je veux citer françois
lance en serre mais je veux dire
formidable texte dans dents dans cette
danse est revu de francs sont enfermés
de pierre magistretti françois ansermet
dirige le service de pédopsychiatrie de
lausanne il fait partie du comité
national d'éthique donc en france mais
il travaille avec pierre magistrati 1 et
psychanalyste l'autre et en neuroscience
et et on voit bien que cette rencontre
dans des mondes qui sont communes
10 incommensurable on peut pas rattachés
mais à un moment donné se sont posés des
questions relatifs à l'humain parce que
évidemment quand on parle de
d'information je veux dire quand on
parle de traitement d'information
regardez bien si on relit de bécanes
je veux dire est qu est ce qui se passe
on va pouvoir transmettre de
l'information et quand il ya une erreur
on va mettre des codes correcteurs
d'erreur ou etc
enfin passons là dessus et l'information
va pouvoir être transmises ma fille
l'autre jour lien d'aucun une revue géo
ado géo ado
or elle me dit elle à 9 ans elle me dit
tu vois pas passer alors l'envoi par
être tous les exosquelettes et machin
les robots tout ce que vous voulez tout
ce qui est dans un peu d'un qui apparaît
en filigrane dans dans le feuilleton la
woman elle dit mais dans on nous dit que
dans trente ans parce que cette pensée
circule chez les enfants dans trente ans
on n'aura plus besoin de la parole pour
communiquer c'est à dire qu'à travers le
traitement d'informations il est noté
cette phrase et me dit mais alors à quoi
ça sert je veux dire en gros si on n'a
plus besoin de la parole parce que en
fait ce qui se passe contrairement aux
bécanes c'est que nous on se heurte en
permanence à quelque chose au malentendu
on se heurte regardez bien ce qui se
passe dans un couple enfin franchement
c'est pas de bécanes qui communiquent
je veux dire au bout au bout de trente
ans et dont elles ont raison changer
d'avis un ou deux à ses sous dans quoi
voyez donc et puis ça a évolué le
regardez bien ce qui se passe au
quotidien je veux dire quand on parle
quand on est dans une réunion de travail
passées c'est compliqué enfin sienne 1
qui trouvent la solution qui me le dise
quoi voyez donc on n'a pas en est loin
de tout ça je veux dire mais là dessus
sur ceux sur ces failles se construisent
les grandes créations
je veux dire sur le malentendu parce
qu'au départ il ya un malentendu en
permanence moi qu'est ce que je sais de
ce que vous entendez d'autres que je
peux raconter le récepteur et jamais au
rendez vous
comprenez par contre de bécanes vous les
mettez donc ce qui se passe c'est qu'il
ya un changement actuel qui est en train
de s'opérer
c'est à dire que pendant longtemps on a
voulu fabriquer d'aider des robots un
peu à l'image de l'homme puis on se
posait la question alors c'est ce
terminator c'est le film blade runner
c'est tout ce que vous voulez pinocchio
pinocchio donc vous voyez donc mais est
maintenant ce qui se passe c'est plutôt
l'homme
à l'image de la machine l'homme avec les
performances de la machine
un homme augmenté mais moi je vais vous
dire il est augmentée pourquoi va être
augmentée pour produire encore plus
élevé qu être bon c'est à dire plus on
est augmentée et plus on va travailler
quoi parce qu'en fait la finalité c'est
quand même ça un loyer de caen vous
rappelons des tas de choses mais pas du
tout vous regardez ce qui s'est passé
depuis trente ans je veux dire on voit
bien que on s'équipe etc
mais alors on y va de plus en plus quoi
de dote donc on est bien augmenter dans
un certain sens et donc c'est dur de
regarder le chrono et puis de poursuivre
sa pensée et et est ce que je voulais
dire c'est déjà voilà c'est cette notion
de malentendus ou d'un communication qui
est extrêmement importante c'est à dire
que c'est sur les points deux buts et
c'est là où on bute un moment donné
qu'on prend appui pour faire quelque
chose c'est parce que eh ben on va se
mettre à discuter parce qu'on comprend
pas parce qu'on va se mettre à négocier
pour reprendre l'expression de dominique
wolton la communication humaine
elle est là dessus quoi et ça je pense
qu'il faut pas l'oublier au moment où on
passe notre temps à informer à envoyer
des données être géolocalisé etc
c'est que cette notion là c'est à dire
ce qui est c'est un rapport à la parole
je veux dire et fondateur est derrière
tout cela
je vais dire ça après derrière tout cela
il ya aussi un questionnement par
rapport à la mort et à la naissance
c'est à dire ces points deux buts et qui
était au départ
qu'est ce qu'on pouvait dire sur la
naissance et sur la mort et dans la fédé
des films sur l'amour
on a construit des choses
extraordinaires et de plus en plus son
temps à les expliquer donc il ya des
zones de périnatalité par un peu on voit
où on intervient de plus en plus
actuellement et il ya des réflexions et
et qui sont posées mais il me semble que
nous on doit pouvoir
ici je dis bien sur ce territoire là je
veux dire qui est assez vaste
non seulement les pauses et que ces
questions mais faire comme vous le
faites ici faire que les personnes se
rend compte par rapport à ces questions
là et qui sont déterminantes
je veux dire d'une certaine manière pour
nous en tant que chercheurs mais aussi
pour les industriels mais aussi pour
ceux qui s'occupent des collectivités
territoriales mais aussi tout simplement
pour ceux qui sont parents qui ont des
enfants qui à un moment donné se trouve
démuni par rapport à tout cela parce que
dites vous bien qu'à un moment donné
combien sont ceux comme l'a dit
christian tout à l'heure qui veulent
notre bien et qu'ils peuvent rompre
dire certaines choses qui vont dire
certaines choses pour notre bien je veux
dire et là on voit bien qu'il ya quelque
chose de formidable à se saisir dans ce
rapport à la technique parce que moi
j'ai pas cheap nos faibles justement
c'est que le rapport à la technique fait
que plus on travaille autour de la
technique
plus on arrive à une zone je veux dire
irréductibles qui est celle de l'humain
alors soit un moment donné on la
conserve
soit on y met un an quelque chose soit
on l'a dégagée et on l'a dit lui c'est
ce que c'est pour certains le projet la
lisez bien le projet transhumanistes
d'une certaine manière ils vont répondre
d'une certaine manière aux difficultés
de ce que peut être lu main en lui
disant hé ben maintenant voilà tu as un
individu es tu vas te bricoler tu vas
totaux reproduire tu vas regardez bien
qu'à 3 on va mettre des capteurs de
partout on va avoir de l'information
et puis on va se bricoler tous les
matins quelque chose mais c'est pas tout
à fait ce que je souhaite parce que
justement à travers l'inattendu et la
création
c'est ce que je préfère voilà je vous
remercie allez